[Music]
to subscribe lega boost all about giving
the kids the right tools to add
behaviors to their models and I'll stun
primarily through the coding so the
coding we see it as a means to an end
and the end is the behavior that the
kids can apply to it to their models and
of course because it's a Lego product
it's all about building as well so we
have a build code and play is a sort of
a motto line for the products or the
play promises we call it in Lego my name
is vini one of my favorite uses for
bernie is slightly over time you
contains his personality he comes to the
number of stock phrases so he has his
own certain sort of poison wine in the
strawberry crack because it was in the
game the personality sort of comes with
that but the kids are able to actually
record through microphones and tablets
their voice into the system and then
turn it into a block that they can then
use as part of their coding and on top
of that they'll be able to put a filter
on top of their voice which sounds like
Bernie's voice so you can actually
really make him say any manner of
phrases - - your family - you can tell
your sister that she stinks if that's
what you want to do and but it really
plays up that pranking role of
it's a longtime secret so obviously with
Lego boost a lot of the the bricks in
set are actually elements already exist
in our palette of Lego elements that we
can choose as designers so the kids have
probably seen these elements before but
what makes boost very special is that
we're actually making a new use for
those elements because they actually
come metaphorically alive by the
behaviors you can put through through
the hardware so in this instance we're
actually giving the kids that
opportunity to take what they know and
maybe even their Lego at home and
involve that as part of the experience
but then make that all come alive in a
new and exciting way
[Music]
thank you thank you don't hurt your
hands